quelques éléments de constat si les
trois plans nationaux de lutte contre la
douleur donc qui ont eu lieu de 98 à
2010 ont permis de progresser sur la
prise en charge de la douleur notamment
par les créations des 250 structures
douleurs chroniques à peu près
la prise en charge de la douleur
chronique et de la formation des
professionnels de santé
sont encore à améliorer il y a encore
des marges de progrès
surtout qu'on sait que plus la prise en
charge est tardive sur ses patients plus
la situation va être complexe et les
possibilités d'amélioration plus
limitées
on sait également que les personnes
présentant des douleurs chroniques sont
orientés tardivement vers les structures
spécialisées et les structures douleurs
chroniques après une errance
diagnostic et thérapeutique en moyenne
c'est des moyennes de cinq ans et
lorsqu'elles sont adressées aux
structures douleurs chroniques elles
doivent en plus attendre un délai
d'attente qui est variable hétérogène
d'une région à l'autre et environ 8 mois
et une fois que cette évaluation est
réalisée par la structure par les
structures douleurs chroniques et si
selon les besoins des patients une prise
en charge est initié les relais avec les
professionnels de ville ne sont pas
suffisamment structurés et enfin à ce
constat il y avait il y a évidemment
malheureusement des inégalités
territoriales d'accès aux soins
spécialisés qui persistent notamment
pour l'accès aux différentes techniques
disponibles pour la prise en charge de
ces patients variables suivant les
structures spécialisées des territoires